[Music]
welcome back now let's
crack straight on shall we with our next
guest who needs a little introduction
it's the shadow chancellor
uh john mcdonnell hello to you thanks
for being on the show
morning morning now before we um
go on with the rest of the interview i
did want to give you the opportunity to
respond to an interview that we did a
bit earlier in the show with uh sir
richard diehl the former head of
mi6 who said that he's troubled by some
of jeremy corbyn's past association
some of which he finds surprising and
worrying
what's your response to those concerns
um well i'm not surprised look this is a
member
a reactionary member of the
establishment so i don't think he'd
welcome a labour government of any sort
to be frank and i'm
disappointed with him but there you are
can i just say to him directly
i think he should spend his retirement
in quiet contemplation of the role that
he played
with regard to the iraq war where over
half a million people
at least were killed he was strongly
criticized as the head of an
organization
whose intelligence took us into that war
so i think he should have a bit of
humility about the judgments he makes
about individuals
and others in the future okay some very
strong words
from you there mr mcdonald um now what
to move on
they were strong um they were strong
words from him with the greatest respect
and if you look at the chilcot inquiry
his organization
was strongly criticized for its role and
he was the head of that
and had severe consequences which were
even living with now
so i think he should spend his
retirement with a bit of humility quite
honestly
okay uh now i do also want to talk about
the
uh interview or the theresa may writing
in the observer this morning she's
making what's really
an unashamed pitch for labour voters
saying that if you're a center-ground
labour supporter the conservatives are
currently the party
uh for you she's also of course talked
about ending austerity i mean are you
worried about this pitch from the prime
minister
well it looks as though she's making a
pitch for labor support because she's
got
so little support in her own party if
you read the stories this morning
they're a group of conservative mps who
are threatening to well have a coup
and then not vote for her own budget
they're falling apart
so it's no wonder she's desperately
looking for support fairly cynically
from
anywhere no i'm not worried at all look
this issue she announced during her
speech at conference about end of
austerity they've announced it three
times already and it's not happened
and isn't ironic that in the very week
that she announces the end of austerity
we discover that members of her cabinet
are being briefed
that families will lose out on 200
pounds a month as a result of the
rollout of universal
universal credit and what the institute
of fiscal studies is saying
75 of the welfare cuts have still got to
be rolled out over the coming couple of
years so
there's no end of austerity quite the
reverse what's happening is the
austerity rolls on
and people are really suffering some of
the most vulnerable within our society
okay i want to talk to you about
universal credit because
labour's current policy on universal
credit which you're very
um openly open in your criticism of it
your current policy is just to pause it
and to fix it so
can you not give us a clear answer now
about whether or not it would be
labour's policy you know in the next
election or if the labour government
would actually scrap universal credit or
if you just keep it despite your
criticisms
i think most people now are coming to
the conclusion it's got to be scrapped
i've been listening to people of the
last few weeks about the role out in
their particular areas i've been looking
at what the government has said that
how they're seeking to reform it the
reforms haven't worked
i think we're at that stage now that
it's not sustainable anymore it's not a
it's not a system that it can work it's
not a system that's providing the
safety's net that people expect it when
they're well they need support
so i don't think i think we're moving to
a position now where it's just not
sustainable it'll have to go
if there were reforms that that we could
be effective
uh fair enough let's reform but we we've
looked and looked and we can't see that
either government proposals
or other proposals could reform it the
system is so
it's in shambles and actually i think
it's actually iniquitous as well
to have a government ministers being
privately briefed that families are
going to lose
200 pounds a month and these are some of
the poorest families
in our community that's just not
acceptable so i i think we're moving
towards a conclusion now that it's
you can't save the thing it's got to go
so if
if that is the case and you say that
it's got to go i mean the principles of
universal credit are hard to
disagree with which is that it should
pay to be in work rather than to not be
in work
and also that the system should be um
simplified i mean 1.9 billion pounds has
been
plowed into universal credit what are
you going to replace it with i mean it's
very easy to point the finger
and quickly well that's what we want to
see but what would you replace it with
well that's exactly what we've been
saying over the last well last year and
since the last general election we now
need a proper consultation
a root and branch examination of how we
can go forward to make sure people do
get the proper support
the principles are bringing benefits
together in one so it's a much simpler
system we all support
but this hasn't done that it's made it
more complex but in addition to that
it seems to have actually penalized the
very people we want to support as i say
we've got four million children out
there in our community
two-thirds of them are in families where
someone's at work that cannot be right
that means wages are so low and the
support for them
through universal credit and elsewhere
is so low as well so
we've got to have a system now that
really works and now i think we've got
to recognize this system isn't working
what system do we now need let's have an
open debate maybe a cross-party debate
about
how we can bring peter again to
re-establish a system which is a proper
security safety net for people where we
do not have people
who are on benefits but are still having
to turn up at food banks last year
over what was a one and a quarter
million food parcels handed out
in the sixth richest country in the
world that that cannot be right
this system is not working now a little
bit earlier we were talking about
theresa may's pitch for labour voters uh
at conference both theresa may and
sanjay java the home secretary spoke
about
the fact that they admired diane abbott
for her resilience in the face of the
abuse that she uh
receives even though they disagree with
some of her policies so
you know in the spirit of trying to
reach out to win over other parties
voters can you tell me if there are any
conservative
mps that you admire
sorry i didn't pick up the last piece of
the question the sound went
um i was just asking you know in the
spirit of reaching out to win over
the opposition's voters are there any
conservative mps that you admire
well to be frank there aren't i've
worked with conservative mps on a
cross-party basis i've worked with david
davis and
on issues around human rights i've
worked with zach goldsmith around the
issue of third runway heathrow
and on those particular issues we've
worked cooperatively etc
and yes at times i've admired them for
the courage in which they've stood up
for their principles of course
justin greene is another one of course
there are people like that who
on their particular issues have been
strong and brave and courageous and i've
i've congratulated them i've appeared on
public platforms with them
but this issue about diana but let me
just say this i find it a bit
hypocritical
that terms salvage avid and the prime
minister have referred to dying in that
way
because it was the conservative campaign
the conservative party campaign
that during the election said a lot of
the criticisms
well that set the dogs onto diane if you
look at what happened in the media
the tory press were abysmal and that was
set
up by the conservative party during
their campaign they
personalized the campaign because they
did not want to debate the policy issues
so i find it
somewhat hypocritical i have to say okay
now a very quick thought from you
because we are running out of time but
i'm interested to get your
reaction to the news that a prominent
saudi journalist
has disappeared in turkey after going
into the saudi arabian consulate there
your reaction it's appalling
if the information is true that's coming
out it's absolutely appalling it's
unacceptable
we along with other nations now should
stand up to the saudi government and
make sure they know
it's unacceptable and if this means
taking action in some form
we should take those actions i've been
on a number of
demonstrations when the saudi regime has
sent representatives here because of
human rights abuses
and if this is another example of that
we've got to be much firmer
mcdonald john mcdonnell thank you very
much